[Music]
in korea
after college i worked here
two and a half years in a light bulb
company
one of the biggest in korea we shipped
out
lots a lot merchandise to especially
new york metropolitan area obviously 2-3
years later
we have a kind of trouble quality
problem
communication problem there is no
telegram no tax no nothing
thursday so company decide
somebody we need to coordinate to stay
in usa
so
i spent almost three years with a
korean company but it's a hard time with
getting money
korea has no money so i gotta monitor
under
our import the buyer meantime i opened
my
eye oh my god this is a this is the
ultimate this road and tell this is like
a usa
then i decide i can make the dream
something i can make then i decide
1971 my own
company which is a barbaric was
founded i often think about
what would it be like if i moved to a
new country now where i didn't speak the
language
where i didn't i couldn't eat the food
like literally couldn't eat the food
and there was no phone there was no way
to communicate with everyone and i just
had to start a new
company by myself with my husband in a
country that i didn't know i can't i
can't honestly fathom that
i went to college and then after college
i worked at pricewaterhouse and went to
school at night
to get my mba and after that i went to
work for what i thought at the time was
my dream job i was working in hollywood
um working for a producer
but on the business side of things and
the the business was moving back to new
york
uh and at the time the company was about
to turn 30.
my dad was turning 60. i was turning 30.
and he kind of sat me down
having not said anything until that
point about you you know we'd really
like you to work in the family business
it's not the space it's not the
merchandise
we need the memphis we need and honestly
i think
can you help me and so it was very
subtle not so subtle
and um at that time it you know i was at
a at a
you know inflection point in my life to
turning 30.
and i said you know what it's kind of
now or never and i would hate for the
business to be
sold or just not having given a shot she
made
the final decision
so i i say hallelujah
he started me in customer service and i
said why am i starting customer service
i have my mba
i can run the financial department i can
do whatever you need me to do and he
said
you have to start with the customers the
way of business
is mechanically technical
completely earthen sky
like a big difference now but it's
concept is the same thing when you work
out when
good relationship with the customer
that's most important
i think he thought okay she's starting
at 30 i'll
consider letting her have some more
responsibility a decade from now so at
when the business was 40 and he was 70.
two years earlier than he expected
he did um hand over the presidency and
then he became chairman
and then i've been running it since then
i remember sitting with my customer
service manager at the time and she
came to my office with a problem and she
said
we have this problem with this customer
what should we do and i literally leaned
in and i said
i have no idea i just became president
yesterday and you've been here for 20
years what do you think
what do you think you should do we
should do and she said i have no idea
andrew used to make all the decisions
and i went
wow this is this is what the change of
leadership you know
is going to look like so i made a very
deliberate intent in building a team
that was a smarter than me
and b empower them to make the decisions
i think that's probably the biggest
difference is the leadership style is
different
and it was it was the appropriate
leadership style for the that time in
the business and i think this is the
right time to
you know we've grown so much so if i had
to make every micro decision it would
it would not be fun a for me nor would
it be fun for my team
once you small thing small dream you can
succeed 110
then you got an encouragement then i
figured out
this is country it's really if you work
hard
and you can succeed
what do i think the american dream is um
i agree with him that
for me america stands for the
possibilities right
i think hard work is important but i
think that's only one element of the
american dream
i think there's other parts though and i
think part of it is not only what you
did for your own family and the families
of the people that worked at the company
throughout the 50 years
but also what you give back 9 11
happened right before i joined the
company
and i remember thinking to myself why am
i doing this other than it's my family
business
and one of the industry leaders at that
time i remember i had the ad up on my
wall
said america needs light beautiful light
and we're responsible for providing it
and to this day like that is the thing
that's my guiding light i look at that
go
i now is the leader of this organization
that physically makes light
is i'm responsible for providing
beautiful light however that manifests
itself
in this amazing country